how can they stop me
you know how can they actually stop me
but if i was in like a in traffic yeah
oh i'm opening all the doors
take her
leave me out of it
because it's got nothing to do with me
i'm just being honest i've also got a
wife and kids you know
i've got to look after myself
i gotta bring food to my table
do you know what i mean
i've got plans traffic i'm opening all
the doors i've got plans
[Music]
what's up guys
happy monday it's good people another
vibes how we doing today
glad to hear it um
so
guys you already know the drill
2023 is around the corner and we need
the log cabin in the woods time is
running out so help us help you let's
get this cult together let's get the
white robes and yeezys they're all very
expensive so please head on over to
patreon.com
forward slash shits in gigs where you
can get not only an episode every week
but you will have you'll be able to
sleep easy at night knowing that you are
helping build
uh the log cabin for generations to come
thanks for the s g cult uh where we will
uh have clapping cheeks
lots of laughter
um tequila on tap it's gonna be live for
at least four generations so
um guys three pound a month tempe a day
you know the drill uh run the p and uh
that's patreon.com for shitsy gigs you
got two years worth of content over
there uh to enjoy and you're you're
paying for a good cause so yeah mom head
on over there
if you are listening on spotify apple
podcast wherever you listen to your
podcast guys please please please please
please do us a massive favor um and
leave a review give us a rating it does
wonders for the show um it helps us kind
of broaden our horizons um
your boys are trying to get rich now we
are we um we're trying to we're trying
to make cake and we're trying to live
lavish and if you do this for us if you
tell a friend to tell a friend leave a
review etc etc it helps us massively on
that journey to be financially free and
just have like [ __ ] you money
that's what we want [ __ ] you money it
helps us help you yeah and that helps us
help you because then we're like oh man
we've got [ __ ] money anymore like
we're not worried about getting
cancelled and then we'll just say what
we want
you'll know how we truly feel yeah
so yeah um please guys leave a review um
and give us a rating and then last but
not least if you are watching this on
youtube
make sure you like and subscribe
two fingers of death ring the
notification bell chirp sitting in the
comments as always guys that also feeds
into the breeding grounds at the log
cabin in the woods 2023 sng cult you're
starting to catch the drift now guys um
so please again like the video if you
like the video
and obviously subscribe to the channel
mission 100k we are
two-thirds of the way there yeah um
and yeah we want that plaque that juicy
youtube plan imagine if they're in the
materialistic shallow youtube plaque of
success we need that we need that
because we are shallow beings
uh we need our ego stroked at every
opportunity
so without any further ado
you're tuning with jmoney fire lord
fuegs we will be your host today if
you're new here
buckle up enjoy because foohat is about
to hit you with a fiery fact of the day
let's get it let's go uh so today's fun
fact of the day guys
done with females and living in fear of
being eaten alive during mating
the male
argonaut octopus has adopted a new way
to mate to avoid physical interaction
the male simply rips off his own penis
and throws out the female to inseminate
herself
a man said i'm just avoiding yet today
i'm avoiding yet today so
just yank it and take it have it that's
all you want from me anyways always take
one from me take it
wow
he said i'm done with females
just done with them
round of applause for the octopus they
always say they're the smartest beings
that's what it's that's what it's coming
to that's what it takes to be the
slightest being yeah
rip off your tool and just dash at home
just dash it and say do it yourself [ __ ]
yourself
literally
[ __ ] yourself
wow that's what they're on he's done
with it that's the smoke they're on
imagine
imagine
that's wild i can't imagine it
i would never do it oh god no obviously
but
you i bleed to death do you know how
like you
you need to be like i can't even get my
words out bro like
you've had it up to here yeah
to get to that point done with females
done with them it's about time that left
a man's mouth
regardless if he's not of the same
species it's about time those words left
a man's mouth because these these not
say it all the time yeah they said
they're done with it done with men done
with men done with men all the time but
i don't see anyone ripping off gash and
dashing at me
because i'll take it with two hands
pile them up like this throw as much
poontang at me as you want and pile it
up yeah
it never happens it's never gonna happen
so props and the and and the chick just
says bet bet i should just
say for that of probably frozen back at
him
wow i don't even know how that patterns
but wow that's a next thing
that is a neck throws the tool at her
and just says do it yourself but with um
octopus or octopi however you call it
um they grow back their tentacles grow
back yeah yeah so the tool probably
grows back so it makes sense so it's
less dramatic but still
is it less dramatic probably not because
even if my tool grew back i'm not kind
of yeah yeah because i don't know this
is all hearsay can you imagine this is
just my instagram
i don't know if it actually grows back
no one's actually told me big man i've
done it and it grows back and even if it
does i'd probably think i'm an anomaly
yeah yeah it doesn't work yeah yeah
i will chop it off and you're right
don't worry don't scream don't panic
it's not going to hurt i drop i mean i'm
screaming for days oh my god i'll just
[ __ ] bleed out i'm not going to stuff
like that no no no no no i'm not ripping
my tool off i'm not on stuff with my
bare hands that's dramatic
facts how does he even do it octopus do
what they want they do what they want
they do do what they want [ __ ] it up
jesus yeah that sounds that's that's a
lot
that's a lot to be done with females and
just say [ __ ] it take my tool and do
what you want go [ __ ] yourself literally
that is damn
that's the best analogy for life
but yeah pretty sure every octopus fact
we've had on here has been like very
telling yeah it is they're they do stuff
they're they're taps yeah
at the same the other one that we did
i'm sure it was about a female
i want to say maybe they eat the male or
something like that we've done probably
two and we've also done one uh an
octopus
like my octopus friend or whatever mark
was teacher teacher that's the one he
was a pervert brother he was so intimate
with that octopus he just didn't make it
around yeah yeah he was a lovely he was
talking all sensual about otters on that
right i hated that i got half of her
locked it
oh before we move on actually yeah yeah
um
have you seen that that bad vegan thing
bad vegan no you've not heard of it
rings a bell but no
bro
is playing more into these swindle
stories bro okay
women are just getting swindled
and it's just a fact now that women get
swindled okay it's actually it's like
eating yes on netflix okay so it's a
documentary called bad vegan right okay
i think i've seen it but i've not seen
it where yeah so i watched it like in
and out but basically is a woman she had
like the most successful like vegan
restaurant in new york okay it was like
hollywood stars would go in there
everything like it was lit sounds cool
um and she was
building a massive business it's the
frog thing
yeah frautic okay i remember the title
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so basically
she started dating this one brother
the brother was was chatting [ __ ]
and was basically like just swindling
her out p
okay he was basically like i've got p
for you this is how he swindled yeah so
pretend i'm him
and you're clueless yeah
okay and we'll role play it say less let
me get into character so get into
character
so me and you met on twitter yeah yeah
and you were seeing me tweet and i was
just funny and smart okay i was funny
and smart okay i'm just going for it
yeah yeah i'm funny i'm smart and i'm
tweeting yeah you're thinking this guy
knows his stuff
so anyway i chirps you and we meet in
person okay say less so we've been
dating for a little while say less
and you've got a cake and suppose you
have a cake okay right and this is where
we it's a way set off okay right
babes well go on let me tell you
something i'm listening you see this two
million dollar debt you're in for
opening up this restaurant yeah yeah
man's gonna take care of that oh
say swear boy's gonna take care of it
just know okay you're special
listen listen listen listen
i've been around so i work i'm in an
essay yes okay i can't really tell you
what i do for for work okay but your
boy's top secret
and i've got i've got forever money okay
so this little two melting
light but why me
because you're just you're eating it
like special yeah i've been to iraq i've
been in the gulf war i've seen [ __ ] okay
i've seen
titties as well
but you're just the thing there's
something in your energy i can tell it
through social media as well there's
something about your energy it's
everlasting
it's illuminating so you're gonna look
after me two mil oh i'm gonna do more
than look after you that's just the two
mil is the is the tip of the iceberg oh
sweat
okay
here's what i'm gonna need from you
i'm listening to prove your loyalty okay
to the cause because i've got secret
[ __ ] going on and the way my account's
set up
i'm gonna need you to run me a young 50
bags okay now obviously you know in the
scheme of things you're two mil done
but in the meantime start looking for
some 10 million pound houses because
that's the minimum budget that we're
going to be moving into oh
i'm going to need 50 racks
this afternoon
sweat that this wire it this afternoon
you need it that quick i need it
yesterday
okay as soon as you give me that
i'm gonna get a better understanding of
where your heart's at in this thing
because obviously i'm gonna take care of
you forever okay but i need to know that
you're for real okay so run me 50 yeah
and then we'll talk okay cool so now
fast forward you've run me 50 okay
babes log on see that 50 yeah
here's what's going on right
i'm part of an elite
secret group yeah imagine illuminati
but for the gods basically
you see your dog your favorite dog in
the whole world
[Music]
he's got about 11 years in him
okay he's going to be immortal i'm just
going to throw it out there i don't want
to give too much away
when i get you into this illuminating
your dog's never going to die
you're going to be taken care of forever
you're never going to die and when we do
die we're going to go off to some secret
place i've seent it
bae i've seen to it
we've got racks we've got power we've
got everything
that 50 was a good taster
how much do you need now
keep your voice down because this is
still secret okay
i'm gonna need a hundred
in about 45 minutes so here's what i
need you to
do take those sweet little cheeks
over to the
to your local branch yeah get me a
hundred this time i need it in cash okay
i need it in cash yeah singles and
twenties unmarked
run it to me
asap
and needs it
i think
this is going to sway him over because
what i'm trying to do is i'm trying to
solidify your commitment okay because
big don's behind the the spectral doors
the curtain yeah
they're not sure about you i ran on the
50 but they know your business is going
well so now i need to run them 100 150
that should patent it
i need the 100 now
and i need it in cash
in singles and twenties singles and
twenties nothing larger than twenties
i'm gonna need you to do that i don't
know why we're still having to have this
conversation because i'm gonna need you
to scurry off and get it i don't think
my banker's gonna give me a hundred bags
well i don't think you're gonna be alive
much longer if you don't
how about that and i love you
but this is bigger than me and it's
bigger than you so you're making threats
now no no no i'm not making anything i
love you i'm gonna protect you i'm doing
this for you so why don't you run the
hundred bucks for us because this is
about
them under because they know i'm i'm i'm
sorry i'm sorry okay i'm trying to get
you in so i can't pay for you you need
to pay for yourself through me
okay you understand me now
get the money
so fam he kept doing this
and then when she's like so bag of
chicks or to one chick one yeah
and then as things will come he might
throw back 10.
so he will take a hundred in two weeks
time she'll be like fam when am i
getting this hundred and he'll be like
it's light man relax i'll tell you what
he's ten
you think i got p yeah cute here's ten
have that i just had that yeah i just
had that on me take that
and that was enough for her to be like
okay [ __ ] that makes sense
if he was gambling the whole thing
overall i think she gave him 1.5
m's
1.5 mil in a space of i can't remember
three years
two three years on
that wow
fam she was in debt
wow she was in debt
wow swindled
and that's all that was all prof from
her restaurant
she went paying wages for him she
scurried off one day
scurried off the staff were like where's
my paycheck
no way i seen pee in three months no way
she scurried off she went pen through
that
oh
what did she say in court i can't
[ __ ] remember fam
she was just chat [ __ ]
but yeah fam i'm i'm just
tired of hearing
about women getting swindled like that
it's just it's
how like how
how how are you letting men do that to
you fam
there's not a woman on this planet
that could say to me
i'm going to pattern you millions
but run me a hundred bags now impossible
the way you just laughed is the wildlife
in their faces yeah 100
and you could be
you could be banging you probably are
banging oh you'd have to be to even get
in the conversation about money you'd
have to be jaw-dropping yeah but it's
still not gonna run i'm not running you
a hundred for nothing
it's just not gonna run
it's wow and they just believe him yeah
they just believe him
that's
i just don't understand like you said
why women are just getting swindled like
this
i don't know to be fair but now that i'm
actually thinking about it guys do get
swindled but not in the same way women
get swindled on fairy tales yeah yeah
fairy tales that are just ridiculous
yeah but men get swindled on pride and
ego
okay
in terms of
let's buy this yard together
it's two mil
and you're like never in a million years
would i buy that house
and then all she has to do is say if you
can't afford it then say you can't
afford it yeah
if you can't afford it say you can't
afford it
because i'm not trying to be with
someone who's broke
so if you can't afford it that's
literally fine
i'm not even judging you but you have to
say that you have to be a man for once
in your life and say that you can't
imagine
yeah
small little princess
small little yeah we're moving in
tomorrow small little stabs yeah yeah
yeah i hear you on that just like when
we did the thing with uh zizi what did
she say
to get a guy to pay for the bill she was
saying do you need any help you need
help with that
excuse me
do you need any help with paying that
bill do you need any help
fam you cut
yeah they eat my ego get the better of
you oh it's the most manipulative
sentence i've ever heard do you need
help with that yo help she knew what she
was doing when she said
how did she construct that sentence
the first time bro do you need any help
with that i'll be scared to say that
if i was here on a date i'll be the
first day i'll be scared to say you need
any help with that
excuse me
excuse me i'll remortgage my house to
pay that rags just for just so i just so
you know that this can never run again
just so you know this could never run
again oh my days so you guys get
swindled like that all the time be fair
to be fair all the time back here now
it's always for women always for always
for girl
yeah always forget is
yeah we're weak you know of course we
are we're pathetic but clearly i'm happy
that women are clearly pathetic as well
yeah because you can spin up a fairy
tale
and it's all good yeah they're in la la
land yeah speaking of actually
speaking of fairy tales do you remember
when um actually [ __ ] out my throat's
getting dry
so you know a couple weeks ago
when um we did the am i the [ __ ] on
patreon for the
what was it the guy getting blackmailed
by his
the guy was getting blackmailed by a
sighting
yeah he cheated on his wife yes
he was banging the sighting and she
blackmailed him when he wanted to leave
her i remember yes and then obviously i
came up with an example of what he could
say
to get out of it from the amount of
messages and comments i've had about
like ra
like
you came up with that lie too
easy
i can't remember too easy so i said like
basically i said that like he'd have to
sit the girl down and just chirps her
again okay and just be like obviously
i want to be with you really but i'm
trying to be a good man i'm trying to go
to heaven
yes i remember i remember
things were different you'd be the one
etcetera it would be your baby that
we've been waiting for but it just
didn't the cars didn't fall right yeah
anyway and then just give her a little
slap on the back spank on the end i'm
gonna miss that
i'm gonna think about it all the time um
anyway
so
i got so many messages and i was
thinking
this man don't know
daddy used to cheat
papa used to cheat
these all don't know daddy used to be a
a notorious fiend
and i would lie
stop referring to yourself as daddy i
have to daddy you should cheat please
please
please
oh my goodness please james don't
it's too much
so yeah
papa used to cheat on a regular basis
and i used to lie on a regular basis
and now obviously that's in the past i
was a young man when i used to do that
and i'm not that man anymore and i'm a
better i'm a better man for it
but it's innate but put baby in a corner
i'll spin a web of lies
and i'll snatch you up at it put me in a
corner
and make me put on that hat
it's long for you early 20j
it's long for you cause i'll spin a web
of lies
you don't even know what direction yeah
he's coming from
she'll be rattled and swimming at the
same time
yeah if i have to put those shoes on i
will that's hilarious i don't want to
have to do it but i'll do it if i have
to do it that's hilarious
but yeah they they were shocked i think
we should have talked about that's light
that's light
of all the things yeah of all the things
i've said in my days that's light work
how you said things in your days boy
i've lied you've said things in your
days lied it's so weird that when i was
younger
i genuinely thought you had to lie to
get
to have it both ways
i think most men thought that back in
that day anyway well back in our day
yeah as opposed to back another yeah
yeah yeah yeah i would because those
days were still early social media days
exactly exactly and like
i met i was i've thought about it before
and i was like why was i like that
and i realized like
the combination of having being
growing up as a kid who genuinely
doesn't
really get that much female attention
to then taking me away from home
and plonking me
in my own yard with my own space
and throwing [ __ ] at me yeah
what am i supposed to do become a
different human yeah you you you get
there's a dark side that comes out of
that fight or flight yeah like a man is
not supposed to live like that out of
nowhere you've got to build up to it
yeah i didn't have time to build up it
all came at once
and i had no choice but to be like well
if anyone finds me remotely attractive i
have to sleep with them yeah obviously
yeah obviously because i don't know if
it's ever going to happen again
and even if it happens 50 times in a row
like i still don't know if it's ever
going to happen again after this so you
have to do it of course of course
that's a cass eating
i was moving like cassie
[Music]
i was moving like cassie without the
tits
that's what i was anyone who showed
remote attention i'm gonna clap them
cheeks
just to show my appreciation
yeah fair enough bro you yeah you had a
you had a great uni time you had a great
evening
back days never mind indeed um so you've
got a nice little segment for us yes so
a lot of guys
funnily enough i had seen this before we
got a lot of like dms about it
but a lot of people sent me a dm saying
um we need to do this on our show
so some
gentleman tweeted
what's the wildest thing a piece of
coochie had you doing this is a safe
space
the responses bro
hilarious okay hilarious
so let me run it back
i'm glad i'm not the only one
i was hitting this 45 year old when i
was 27.
she had me so gone one day she had to go
to work for an emergency she asked me to
take her husband to lunch bruh i bought
this [ __ ] a meal and took it to him i
told him i was a nephew
what i told him i was her nephew
that's what
insane brother what
how would
how would you not anticipate follow-up
questions
husband fam
nephew i've met her family i've never
met you my life
i've never heard of you
brother what yes brother
why why does he even have to take him to
lunch
what kind of sick [ __ ] is she into bro
bro
in
in bed with her doing horoscope quizzes
and watching real housewives i was
finished
horoscope courses
[Laughter]
that's funny had to have to climb two
stories to see shawty in the pouring
rain while it was freezing at 3am i got
topped while i was napping in her bed
though shorty just had me feeling like i
was in the notebook
in the
notebook when i tell you i was listening
to jonas brothers religiously for a
whole year you man wouldn't believe me
jonas brothers i couldn't tell you once
for pom for pum
nah come on man this girl had me shed in
tears to k-drama
drama
[Laughter]
that's actually jokes
you ever watch queer eye while eating
vegan food oh no no
the poem was busting
to have me watching queer eye whilst
eating vegan food
[Music]
i can't imagine what problem that is ah
i got baptized for her
stop stop
stop
wow
i jacked off to her bitmedia
no you didn't
yes he did that's sick yes he did that's
a snapchat take
wow
sure you had me so toxic i egged her
house for about six months straight
after he broke up
gave her kid my playstation no
bro this is mad bro this is mad bro
i'm currently on a flight to rome with
her family
[ __ ] i'm currently on a flight to rome
bro
yo ah
i went to a pregnancy class with a girl
that was having another man's baby nah
see that's
why are you smashing her
why are you smashing her he's got a kink
bruh why are you smashing it why are you
smashing her he's got a king he likes a
pregnant chick that's disgusting
hey
you don't kink shame
no you don't kill me no remember no
remember james
your words we don't kink shame remember
[Music]
being a test dummy for her to learn how
to wax
mandem are doing the most yeah one guy
tweeted have you ever been to a saucy
santana concert
do you know who saw the santana
i didn't know until i until it came up
after i saw that you know who sources
who's that you've seen this [ __ ] before
saucy santa
i promise you
i don't know who that is let me see
you've seen them on socials you must
laugh
[Laughter]
bro
are you up to
[Laughter]
that went to this concert
no
are you into this yeah
that's [ __ ] funny
so you know the brother in it no i don't
know who's never seen his bread before
no i've seen him on social's bear
bear
he looks like he just like does
underground vogue competition
i'm not gonna lie
i never knew
saucy did music
i've seen i don't know where to call him
him or her i would say her
i've not seen her
so i've only seen her face i've never
seen a rap or anything i've just seen
her face on social before or like do i
i've seen all that memes and gifs and
stuff but i didn't know she was actual
rapper wow wild to me bro when i saw
that laugh homeboy went to a saucy
santana concert concert
wow
concert
wow
pretending to be a landscaper after a
dude came home from work early
just surveying the [ __ ] building bro
can you imagine
you don't know the torture of learning
the whole macklemore album justin just
to impress a [ __ ] [ __ ] i was in hell
macklemore oh
to be fair home truths
there's some home juice it's not that
bad you bumped a bit michael moore nah
not michael moore but there was one time
i took a girl out on a date
and my boy and i didn't know anything
about this girl and she was banging
so my boy told me
he didn't he didn't know her and we were
like
chatting about it we were at work
chatting about and i was like oh i don't
know what um i don't know nothing about
her i just know that we're going on on
this on this date
and then my boy was in the office with
me was like all i know is she loves
chris brown okay and i was always it and
he was like yeah because i was like
singing that chris brown song and she
like stopped me like in the hallway one
time oh my god i love christmas i was
like stay less so i remember i pulled up
at a house how long was it which album
which chris ram album it was um
what album was it what's the one with
the um
i know he ain't gonna make it to my bed
it's got privacy on it as well
we're talking five six years ago yeah
it's called heartbreak at a new moon
yeah heartbreaking yeah heartbreaking
full moon album yeah yeah it's all right
yeah it was all right yeah yeah bangers
on there yeah
bangers on there yeah i've got burgers
yeah yeah and as i'm waiting for our
house
outside
i'm sitting there chilling and then
i was like [ __ ]
i've got nothing in the tank so i
scrolled to privacy and just played it
and i fast forwarded it like
a minute in so she thought it was just
it was yeah yeah
though yeah yeah smash
no
it is what it is
um
right
again the wildest thing a piece of cooch
has had you doing
her husband came home from work so i had
to pretend i was the nephew from her
daddy's side till this day he still
calls me nephew every single time he
sees me how many times has he seen you
he's clearly still
in them cheeks bruh what's all this
nephew stuff um
i'm telling you now my
could never have a grown man in the yard
and be like oh this is my nephew
from my dad's side what
what
what are you all about what what are you
on about
who are you who are you because we've
been married brav and everyone was in
there
who are you
it's my nephew
now
right
the girl told me to pick her up from her
house i was confused because she lived
with her boyfriend but i said [ __ ] it
maybe he's not home when i pulled up
they both came out the house she kissed
him goodbye and hopped in the back seat
of the car like i was getting like she
was getting in an uber oh
she's got balls of steel bollocks
brother
she's got balls of steel he replied to
me zone to be saying now that i think
about it this falls under the category
of the wildest things she's ever done
for some dick
facts
kissed him goodbye and got in the car
like backseat backseat like it isn't
didn't even inform him i'm gonna pretend
you're an
he play the role quick oh man you can
always rely on man to play the role yeah
yeah you can always
rely on a man to play man is trying to
get none that night he'll play any role
he can get yeah any role you turn him to
play he'll play
don't even you don't even have to tell
him you didn't need to tell him he's
going to play the role
because he definitely clapped that night
oh 100 they never speak about it oh fam
100 and
you know you're clapping as soon as she
does that kind of play you like oh of
course i'm clapping tonight because
she's nuts oh she's crazy she doesn't
rate her relationship she doesn't rape
me
she just wants what she wants yeah yeah
so i'm now banging you tonight so that's
fine fair enough
i met a 50 year old puerto rican couple
when i was 19 at my job wife was fine as
[ __ ] still long story short first time i
smashed the wife i had a weird feeling
heard a noise looked back and the
husband was watching man paid me for
over a year to [ __ ] his wife while he
watched
i don't think i could do it i was just
about to ask you which
banging chick
banging chick
absolutely banging thick nice titties
asian as well
okay
fair
nah
with the husband watching he's obviously
going to be wanking as well isn't he
yeah some cuck-holding yeah of course
he's going to be wanking yeah
no no
no that turns my stomach
it just deletes all of her penguins to
me yeah because i just like i don't know
like
oh i don't know
it's just something too creepy for me
it's just weird
oh
i couldn't do it i can i don't think i'm
getting the zone
i don't i can't have another
being in the room when i'm trying to
smash yeah i mean
no it just won't pop for me at all
11th grade i caught two buses then
walked from the west bank expressway all
the way back to ames to get to our house
i misjudged how far that [ __ ] was i
walked for about three hours straight
no
three
hours three hours straight for some
[ __ ] to be fair once you're like 40
minutes in you can't go back yeah you
can't go no matter how far it is you
can't go back
and that's facts you literally can't
that's facts oh it's nuts bro i have
another man's wife tattooed on my
forearm
she's swimming at everyone
just as i literally said earlier you
mandem can't get swindled like that
took a charge for her little brother no
swindled no
that's
that is
disgraceful swind it
fam
disgraceful
went to her job to beat up a co-worker
that was bothering her and her boyfriend
was too [ __ ] to do it got a friend of
mine to give that same boyfriend a job
working night so i could be with her
[ __ ] bro
bro
can't forget about those times i'd wake
up at 5 30 a.m in the winter to ride my
bike a mile to my girlfriend's crib to
smash before school while her parents
went home until one day someone stole my
bike was walking in 25 degrees just for
some cheeks oh bro
to be fair i'm saying all these things
that when you said about the 5 30 that
same yeah the chris brown yeah it was
the one that had me up jimmy with her at
six o'clock in the morning
and i didn't even smash i think i know
who it is yeah i know who it is she had
me jamming at six a.m for weeks you
spoke about this on here yeah yeah i
think yeah six a.m bro for weeks oh
i was knackered
[ __ ] i promise you now james [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that there's no woman that could
tell me to train at 6 a.m brother i
promise you
i know myself i know you i believe you i
promise you i believe you bro it
couldn't happen but it wasn't even it
was i don't know man she just had me up
and then just
it wasn't that case of like oh do you
want to train at 6am it was a case of
like oh we should train together i'm
like oh yeah i'm down yeah yeah
and then like oh we can do this and do
that and i'm like yeah sounds decent and
then she was like cool like tomorrow and
i'm like oh i'm down i got nothing on
tomorrow and then she was like cool well
i usually train at like six so six
in your head you thought pm obviously no
you didn't i knew it was am when she
said it and i was like right
we've been talking about this
for ages
in terms of like we've been talking
about training together for like five
minutes so the whole five minute
conversation has led up to me agreeing
to go at six a.m so it's either i agree
or i lock off this whole thing and i'm
like oh god oh [ __ ] that i'm not
training with you that's exactly what i
said i know you would have that's
exactly what i was lost in her i was
lost with her bro
lost with her so iron man six is
weeks of it [ __ ] that and then i had to
work and obviously jim was at work so i
would train at six till seven half seven
then i'll just be shattered fat brother
i'll be shattered and then i'd start
working like nine i'll be disorientated
by the time i started my head was on the
desk
i'm not doing that for anyone
i'm sleeping until eight and then making
my way to work at 8 45.
i tell you that for free
that's impossible impossible it was hell
it was hell hang tight man you're you're
a better man than me i promise you i'll
never do it again i know you weren't
damn near got a purple al tattooed
because it was a favorite animal and
color thank god the shop was closed oh
my god the man was there
he wouldn't have backed out i already
know he wanted oh he's a [ __ ] oh he's
not backing up he would have done it
purple
oh
bro why is this happening
i was a side [ __ ] for five years and
three relationships
the [ __ ] must have been good
all three of them all three of them it
sounds like he just couldn't do anything
else maybe
maybe somebody can do anything else may
[ __ ] really different relationships
bro i was i was the same girl and she
went through three two three yes oh five
years in three relationships five years
in three years yeah so she got a new man
numerous you always stayed the side
[ __ ] still the side deal oh wow
shameful shame but yeah that's it
it was loads but i was like yeah he it
down that's shameful but it was a good
thread though there was responses to
that thread i bear that thread yeah all
of you man hit me up in the dmc all
right talk about this talk about sir
you've i've heard you yeah i heard you
yeah speaking of talk about this talk
about this um we've been getting dms
about this show that we probably need to
watch i already know what show is the um
yes yes what's it called i don't know
it's the spin-off of the the tank
lover's blind yeah yeah i saw the
trailer when i was watching love and
blind i saw the trailer for this thing
and i was like i'm not watching this i'm
not watching this it just looks [ __ ] but
everyone keeps saying this it's sick so
i'll watch it i'm gonna watch first
episode and see i'll watch it this week
all right cool um what's it called
ultimatum ultimate oh mayhem um but i
think yeah i think we should give it a
solid go all right and then we can do a
breakdown together all right say less
all right but we'll do this week we'll
watch it yeah we'll watch it this week
probably like eight to ten episodes
anyway so yeah yeah but um do you know
what the premise is yeah i know the
trailer i've seen the trailer right bet
so it could be interesting it could be
awful and if it's awful i'm just going
to say it's awful we're not even going
to yeah we're not going to entertain
this silly little chat if it's [ __ ] i'm
not watching it
i am not watching it fair enough um but
yeah you said you had a fan request
hmm
isn't that juicy
i ain't reading that like this in a
minute james wow really
like this in a minute jason oh wow okay
oh my goodness
it's a long one as well all right i'm
listening be careful be careful buckle
up brother
okay okay
so
my ex and i lived together lived
together past ten sorry
i was in an extremely toxic relationship
with a narcissist and didn't know how to
leave believe me
when girls say i want to leave but i
can't it's real
even when you try to leave they can get
violent so that so you have to play your
cards right
we lived together and he cheated many
times he hated that i always caught him
out on his phone
stupidly of him he gave me his password
to trust to show i could trust him
already a [ __ ] negative but i
reversed who knowed him
after after i was truly done with this
[ __ ] he came home drunk one morning with
half a bottle of captain morgan's dark
rum
oh
i took the bleach from the bathroom and
filled the rest of the bottle with it
obviously
my gcse science didn't come in handy
because the bleach turned the rum white
and now it looks sus
so i paced up and down the kitchen and
decided to pour it down the drain
i then put laxatives in his protein
powder
hair removal cream on his receding
hairline as he slept
no punctured his bike every time he got
it repaired
got him fired from his job by sending an
anonymous letter to the boss's boss
saying he's making girls uncomfortable
at work with sexual harassment
being unemployed he then went to the
streets
i think that last episode of power went
to his head
[Laughter]
i also went to the park and burned all
his arsenal tops then made him think he
left it at one of his friends houses and
he loves to bring a change of clothes
everywhere
on his birthday pause
he likes to bring a change of clothes
everywhere he goes he's a chi oh an
abomination he's an abomination
that's what he is he's a serious chief
he just tells her to his face i'm
bringing spare clothes is that
abomination wow
on his birthday he passed out drunk and
on his back and threw up
i found him and walked away
she wanted him to choke on his own [ __ ]
his best friend found him and rolled him
on his side saying he easily could have
died if nobody caught him i should have
closed the door and let him rest in
peace
james this is the wildest thing i've
ever read i don't think you understand
what is this
is this from an anonymous account or
does she freed us up she freed it up
i've got first things attempted murder
that's attempted murder it's the wildest
thing i've read james i don't think you
get it
you own me a couple bags so when he came
home asking me to count his drug money
for him i'd always take some to repay
myself as he would always
as he always said he needed it to reload
and couldn't spare any
then twice he came him drunk and passed
out so i took his entire wallet filled
about filled with about 500 pounds in
cash each time and went to put it in my
bank and then bin the wallet
when he woke up
he went mad looking for it i proceeded
to tell him i proceeded to help him look
for the wallet and ended up saying oh
his boys must have stolen out of
jealousy of how well he was doing on the
streets
she
she's evil
they're jealous of how well you're
getting on in the street
this is the wildest thing i've read wow
this is the crux of it now
the finale
his arse finally got caught and he ran
after jamaica to avoid to avoid prison
i managed to get his new passwords by
using iphone tool by using iphone
password password tool where you can use
the list of all passwords and hacked his
facebook snapchat instagram to expose
his nudes after photoshopping his dick
to half the size then dm'd a bunch of
married women
the photo hoping their husband would
punch him up on site if they ever saw
him wow question did i ever go too far
honestly no
i'm a fire sign you don't play with me
i said to her jesus christ definitely
the wildest things i've ever read will
get on the pod at some point
all right that's
there was twists and turns so let me
give you
a synopsis
she was in a toxic relationship
she said trust me when i say i want to
leave and it's hard to leave it's real
live together
donnie was a cheat sheet
he was a cheat
yeah he said you know what if you don't
believe me hear my passwords
gave her the passwords
he came home drunk one day
captain morgan half a bottle she decided
to throw a bit bleach in there but she
thought [ __ ] it
he's gonna suspect something i could go
to pen straight away
lock that off put laxative in the
protein powder put hairline receding
cream on his head punctured his tires
and sent an anonymous letter to his
boss's boss
saying that he's harassing women at work
burnt his arsenal tops
in the park blamed it on his boys
found him laying drunk on his side no
throwing up on his up like this didn't
turn him over wanted to close the door
and let him rest in peace
saying
saying
how was stole
stole his drug money and said said his
boys who are jealous of how well you're
doing on the streets
and also photoshopped his own tool half
the size and send it to
wives and husbands in jamaica so they
can bang him up on site if he ever
clocked him
question did i ever go too far
i have no idea how bad this relationship
was
so i'm gonna say
no
apart from the sick thing
that that's death what's it what is the
closest i'll let rest in peace yeah she
wanted him to die there
there's actually not even wanted him to
die there's like she intentionally let
him die yeah that's attempting as soon
as she walked off
in her mind he's dead
i don't think we're grasping this as
soon as she saw him clock the situation
and carried on walking in her head oh
he's dead now
fam she put bleach in this captain
morgan's bottle
what are you on about that too that was
the first thing she said traffic
she would bleach it
she said if it wasn't for the gcse
science yeah yeah it could have she
would have killed him and she would have
been happy if it didn't change color we
wouldn't be reading this message today
it should be in bed
we would have got it we would have
received it in an envelope
bro
the wildest
message i've ever seen so that's
attempted murder twice twice
twice attempted murder
yeah i'm sorry that's
so i don't because obviously it doesn't
actually state what he did
all she said he was toxic and he was a
narcissist
and when you say trust me when you want
to leave it's hard and i said
um
they even try and get violence i'm
assuming yeah i'm assuming it was dark
dark yeah it was dark and he put paws on
her
so
the only reference i have is when i see
stuff like this in like series and the
eastenders thing eastenders type thing
yeah
yeah
it's dark it does yeah they died too
the man don't get killed in them ones as
well
they get doppy because they have to fend
for them the wives have to look after
themselves so it's understandable yeah
when you see a third person's
perspective
wow so yeah she must have been in a
in a really dark place bro for these
things to even be nonchalant to even
type these and send them
from her account
she must have been in a she thought [ __ ]
all the odds because i'm out of this
[ __ ]
and i don't give a [ __ ] nah fam
nah fam
i'm leaving
all this oh it's
i'm leaving
like she she said it's hard to leave
okay i'm not i'm not judge i'm not like
trying to like input on people's
relationship this is as far as i'm
concerned it's a hypothetical situation
okay as far as i'm concerned because all
this is
yeah i'm not an
accessory okay so
but she said she was stealing bags off
him he would come in say count my drug
money and she'll steal cake
he can't buy train ticket
but you say that let's take top boy for
example curtis and what's her face it
was hard for her to leave oh yeah but he
weren't leaving the yard
curtis weren't leaving the yard
he was
he was a little bit i didn't get with
her in the yard
i'm sure he i can't remember to be fair
i can't remember she was plotting and
scheming but that's that was hard for
her but she was on the phone to jack
saying pick me up yesterday
pick me up so she was trying to leave
and as soon as she got the opportunity
to leave she dipped a taxi straight to
london how scary was that scene
how scary was that scene i said drive
drive open the man was like okay i'm
going to open the door i'm going to open
the door
oh
as soon as it man revved it
if you were the sex driver would you
open the door
i don't know it depends if i was in his
exact spot and the thing open i wouldn't
open the door because i've got every
right to just drive like how can they
stop me
you know how can they actually stop me
but if i was in like a in traffic yeah
oh i'm opening all the doors
take her
leave me out of it
because it's got nothing to do with me
i'm just being honest i've also got a
wife and kids you know
i gotta look after myself i gotta bring
food to my table
do you know what i mean
i've got plans traffic i'm opening all
the doors i've got plans
you know
i'll look back bro i look back and say
i'm sorry who's you is that that's what
oscar who's who is it his
gal cat get a [ __ ] up he sounds serious
he sounds deadly serious
i'm sorry
at this point
it's powerful
it's so powerful he's not even scouse i
heard he's american i think that he's
english he's english okay yeah yeah but
he's not even from liverpool did
yes and he don't play when it comes to
his weapon
man sat up with duchette everything fam
stealing all the the drugs everything
bam
let her foreign fam when he walked up
into shelly's nail salon and and the
other chick saying are you shelley and
he's like no i'm blah blah blah it's
like my name's curtis and he she wasn't
saying his name is there any reason
you're not saying my name you forget my
name and she was like
no sorry no sorry curtis
his dick went hard there oh right he
loves that power play that sexual power
play yeah yeah yeah yeah she he
instilled so much fear in her it was
unbearable
unbearable all she had to do was swallow
spit that's all she could do fam curtis
was running game on all of these like
she was
that sister was so pissed she got
pregnant with him rags
because my man
that's my child
that's my child what was his sister
called i can't remember she was a [ __ ]
it was a [ __ ] i couldn't believe what
was happening she was a [ __ ] if she
would ah i don't know i would i would
want to fight the living christ out of
her i want to fight her i'll be fighting
her every day
she's lucky she was pregnant
oh if i wasn't pregnant if i was her i
wasn't pregnant arms swings
swinging she was a [ __ ] she was a [ __ ]
a full-blown [ __ ] and also
fam
me and you are boy boys but if your hoe
leaves you and runs to london you could
never tell me we'll go in london to pick
her up
excuse me
she's gone
we saw her she was screaming in the taxi
[Music]
even if she's got my you yeah
100 even if you've got my you don't
listen to me brother you want to have
this conversation if she's got it this
is all hypothetical you're curtis now
you're not through had yeah i just want
to clarify okay because i don't want
this to get ugly
because i don't i don't know where your
head's at right now
because you sat up in your chair said
even if she's got my you just speaking
i'm speaking brother
if we're out shopping
and we see her pregnant ass run into a
taxi and get in and scream and drive
yeah and i saw that with my own eyes
and you say we'll go in london to pick
her up yeah
[Music]
i say fam i don't think she wants to be
here i'm just gonna throw her out there
i know you you'll love her and if you're
tired all this stuff i don't think she
wants to be here
and i don't feel entirely comfortable
driving to the other end of the country
that's a four and a half hour drive and
they actually drove they drove in their
shitty whip it wasn't some mitsubishi
type yeah yeah
i'm not doing it
so we can do what find her
we're just going up to i can sell my
house and we're just gonna find her are
we oh well we're gonna go to i know she
chats to shelly in the nail salon i know
where her mum lives or
yeah i say and where she refuses to
leave bro
what if she says she ain't coming back
what are your plans then
and i said that's my child she's coming
nah
he's curtis is different yeah he's
different he would never
yeah
he's lucky he's an actor fam he's lucky
he's an actor duchene held his own in
there in that coffee shop
duchenne doesn't when he's in that cafe
he doesn't play
this is his four walls
this is my domain whatever you say i
don't give a [ __ ]
he literally
doesn't give a [ __ ] he doesn't give a
[ __ ]
this is this is my dunya whatever you
need to say say it because i'm not
afraid of you you found literally he's
not afraid of anyone a man said
oh
what did he say i'm trying to be nice
he said why don't we just skip to not
nice yeah
why because you're just chatting chat
and [ __ ] less skipped or not nice you
don't want this
you don't want this
over here he doesn't even like he
[ __ ] hates her
sully wants her tumped up fam over yet
he hates
imagine what he does for a yet he loves
if it was shelley
he wouldn't have made it out of the cafe
he wouldn't have it
want to made out he wouldn't have it
could never have been jelly
it would have stopped episode six it
could never have been shelley it
wouldn't make episode eight he'll burn
everything
duchenne doesn't play he doesn't play
[ __ ] he really really does a lot being
top boy oh i couldn't handle it it's a
lot being told no wonder he was having
heart palpitations every other day fam
it's just too stressful [ __ ] help so
i said i'd rather be in that lieutenant
stage jack i'd rather be jack
carr
she was just lips in [ __ ]
she was just lips and [ __ ] and
telling youngers what to do oh bro she's
she's gotta unlock she's got everything
on yeah she she's got her ting pattern
duchenne's just stressed
sully does what he wants sully did what
he wanted you get 50 revenue
and you just come in and out as you
please you're a part-time guy and i'm
giving you 50
he brings all the smoke though oh when
you call on him sully brings all the
smoke because when he said i need you
i've saved you now i need you to head
off to morocco
he was there he was there jamie was
shaking
jimmy was shaking thinking nothing
not him
when man sat down
yo i didn't know there's scars on his
face i did not expect that just straight
from getting batted up in a into some
shop but straight to morocco they don't
have time to heal from deshane said get
on a plane
i couldn't be a road man i promise james
i couldn't be a roadmap neither could i
i promise you i wouldn't make it a week
i wouldn't make it they're lifestyle
choices
i couldn't make it
i'd think i'm bad mine and literally
until you bump into a bad man
oh yeah until i bump into a real one or
not even till i bump into a real one
it's probably when duchenne says
uh valleys and burners yeah bali straps
baddies and bugs
tonight
what do you mean
they've got sally and we need to get him
how where where oh they've got a [ __ ]
dunya rp and pekka
we're getting him
we're gonna run up and we're gonna kill
everyone
yeah no no no no no sorry sign up for
this
i just sign up for this i just want to
sell weed that's all i want to do
sell weed on the streets get a couple
change here and there i want to sleep in
and sell weed i don't want to shoot
nobody i'm not trying to get violent
man are shooting at me and i'm shooting
at them
for sullivan
sullivan
he got himself into this he did with his
silly little cousin
he got himself into this no he's ah i
forgot she's pebbles yeah she's a piece
of this [ __ ] she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] i
hated her i hated her i hate them [ __ ] i
forgot about that i hated pebbles i
forgot why why did you even get nice
i [ __ ] hate she needed to hold a bang
in her face oh
she oh she invigorated me fam
i hated pebbles jesus christ pebbles is
a useless little cow absolute snake and
even after that she was telling sorry we
can run this you know
never look at me again
pebbles never look at me again
we're no longer family you're we're
literally not family we're done we're
done that's it she thought she could
bring the ute to him and everything is
blessed
i'm punching you in your forehead
suddenly hold his held his own though he
got rocked in that spot they kicked his
[ __ ] head in they beat the crap out
of him van winning went into the gym
and ho boy rocked up to him he clapped
him with the play
i for ra i said wag one what is it
i said what is it i haven't got i don't
know what who's got what i i'm telling
you now i'm not going in that gym
promise you i'm not going in there
sally holds his own bro yeah he does
anything for family he holds it he
literally gets it done i would be
thinking i don't really know how this is
going to work people could come to me
and i'd be like what suggestion do you
have exactly because it sounds like
you're in a lot of trouble
and you want me to bail you out yeah
i've [ __ ] to do today i've got a couple
bags for you
but that's about it yeah i've got
deposit on a cheap yard in romford
but other than that
you you literally sound [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] and then she was like
after man smacked him in a plate it was
like oh you can drop me home here bro
but you can't go home anymore yeah
yeah you literally can't go you can't go
home what do you mean
i just live there
you think you can go yard that's mad
you're dead pebbles close the door
close the [ __ ] door pebbles
oh it's done
she could never be my my niece she could
never be my niece and after all said and
done she literally just got to scurry
round ends that's it
la dee da
after she sold man out i [ __ ] hated
her
oh it was the worst thing that was a
betrayal and a half it was he held his
own though what played he took long to
bang that french as well i would have
banged on night one yeah
they did a little yeah yeah yeah
um but anyway
yeah she tried to kill homeboy she i
[ __ ] [ __ ] it up this is this dilemma
thing she tried to kill him and that's
that's a bit much did you go far
considering the fact that we don't know
the ins and outs of the relationship
we only have your account
i'm
going on a whim to say you thought all
of this was the only thing you could do
to get out of this situation respectful
fair play um
but did you i would say did you go far
the answer is yes the answer is yes you
went very far on more than one occasion
twice on more than one occasion you let
you wanted to kill him twice that's
that's some serious [ __ ] and she's not
remorseful
that begs the question of how bad was
this relationship
clearly bad violently bad
that's scary stuff it is scary stuff
that's what i had to read is bro the
wildest thing i've ever read
wow she wanted to drop him
so yeah i'm happy you're out of that i'm
happy you're healthy i'm happy that you
got to send us this dm and ask us to
talk about it but boy
wow i'm sorry i had to go through that
that's that's long that's all long
wow
did you have a trash nose as well
i did forgot about that fam
yeah when i read this i was vex okay
caption company is offering 15 pounds an
hour to watch porn from the comfort of
your home
exactly excuse me is exactly the
expression i had as well
explain
bed bible wants to pay one lucky person
20
15 pounds an hour
an hour sorry to watch an online
pornographic to watch online
pornographic videos and gather
information and data points on certain
topics such as sex positions duration
number of orgasms male versus female
ratio hair color distribution and
language distribution
the data will then be used to conduct an
in-depth report about tendencies
statistics in porn videos
the job ad reads
want to get paid to watch porn
then bedbible.com has the perfect job
for you
we are taking a deep dive into ins and
outs of pawns and we need your help to
do this applicants for their head of
porn research role just need to be aged
21 and over for the dream role and as
the position is 100 remote it doesn't
matter whereabouts in the world you are
wow
why are we indeed bro
if i'm to be fair i'll be terrible at
the job why
because i'm not in in the first three
minutes and i'm forgetting i'm on job
yeah
you have to watch it like a series yeah
no i'm turning it off yeah oh fat i said
this is a juicy one or fat
and i'll i'll probably kick it right and
then wake up
hair color this that i don't know i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah hair color yeah
yeah what language does it speak in
english i don't know i'm not watching
i'm not watching german porn i'm english
how long will they do in this position
i don't know oh wow i'll just send them
the link there your answers deserve
your answers desolate run me my 15 an
hour fam i'm knackered
i've watched what i need to watch i've
been wanking today 1581 i'm sorry
yeah
i'm [ __ ] scared who told you to wait
is it there it is
sociable it's a non-negotiable cause it
is of course it is
yeah when i read that i was like rah boy
that's a new thing that's really really
annoying
and they just want the information from
one person yeah that's big man just
watch it yourselves i don't understand
yeah just watch your [ __ ] cells it
makes no sense as to why they um
why they want to auction that out or
whatever just just pay anyone to do that
that is wild um i've also got
two do you have one more thing no no so
we're going to do the
[Music]
the question and answer segment on
that we did on twitter twitter instagram
instagram cool
so last question that's what i'm about
to find now
right guys so um last week we asked you
what's the worst funniest way you've
been friend-zoned
and yeah man the responses were hella
hella juicy so i'm a running for you now
quotations it's like i'm sean paul and
you're blue control but i'm looking for
my beyonce
blue cantrell is isn't is not the one
she's literally not the one
blue can drill
ah
two dates in he said you're gonna fall
in love with me and it's gonna end badly
of course i disagreed a month later he
left me at the pool party with the bill
and i never saw him again
he's a piece of [ __ ] boy a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's in his head he's
thinking i warned her about this
i literally did you did it
i warned you this is going to end badly
this is a mistake babes
he's like no that's gonna be fine trust
me i'm a big girl less you're a big girl
yet
yeah run it up belvedere magnum
run it up ah that's hilarious
had an opportunity so i offered to
what had an opportunity so i offered to
skull [ __ ] him he said it was against
his religion
friend zoned
mad
that's mad
he told me i need to find a vemma
version of you i am a female
oh i told her she looked pretty and she
replied love my [ __ ] and then spotted
me
yo
bought me a drink in a club whilst
cheers in he looked to me in the eye and
said to friendship
live it she borrowed my playstation to
entertain another guy
took a girl home for a candlelit dinner
just before just before serving she
asked when will the others get here
i'd what would you do if you were the
brother
what would you do
when are the others getting in if i said
to you i'm the girl right yeah you're
you're about to dish me some rice and
pizza slime i'm like
when are the others getting here by the
way
candle lit brother i promise you even if
it's my yard i'm dropping the pot on the
front i'm walking out
i'm not answering this silly little
question
there's only two plates laid out here
what do you mean two plates one candle
and the table's this big
the others the where did the others get
in here who were the others because
there's no in your wildest dreams it
could never be just me and you
that's what she's saying long story
short your wildest dreams it's not me
and you
so where's everyone else
i'm dropping the ting and i'm walking
out it's tough bro oh [ __ ] off my homie
set me up with a girl when i first met
her she said to him he ain't that cute
whilst he was there brother
bro
my crush was my bro's best friend mid
snog he stopped and says i look too much
like my brother i can't ah
fair play i can't ah
that would be frustrating i wrote her a
song
and she said she loved it and there's a
girl out there for me somewhere
every time after we'd have sex he'd spun
me and say safe my g i needed that
no
you're just a hole literally just a [ __ ]
bucket
safe my g i needed that
i really needed that
you're you're bredrin
you're real brethren i [ __ ] needed
that thank you so much i needed that
now i can just get on with my day you're
my life
[ __ ]
nah
hit me up with
you up text on a saturday night i go
around and she leaves with her ex while
i'm stuck looking after their kid
[ __ ] sake told the [ __ ] i had
feelings for her and she replied oh
really bro
gave him a vows day card and he laughed
and said your jokes
you and i both know this ain't gonna
happen but i'm glad you told me so you
can get out your system
family
say that again one more time
no wrong one you and i
both know this ain't gonna happen but
i'm glad you told me so you can get it
out of your system
[ __ ]
dark and deep and twisted bro that's a
shank and a twist
that's a shank and a twist brother so
you can get it out of your system and we
never have to talk about it
let's [ __ ] put a pin in that because
i don't want to revisit it
i don't want to [ __ ] revisit it
so i'm happy you got out
told me i was too skinny she wanted
something to hold on to i took it
personally
bro something to hold onto
when i was 17 16 17 yeah
i was um chatting to this one girl
oh my god santa's one girl and we were
getting along and one of my boys was
friends with her and went to college
with her and then he said oh you might
have been chatting in it and i was like
yeah yeah and he was like oh do you want
me to see if she's down
and then i was like yeah yeah fam he
bailed me the next lunch time
he was like so i spoke to her and i was
like say that's what she said she said
she only dates hench guys
and he hung up
[Laughter]
bro
you better left your jaw dropped
couldn't respond all you heard was a
dowel toed off
the phone
that's it hung up
i was heartbroken bro i hit the gym so
hard that flip phone as well
pharah's edge
bro she only likes hedge guys
this afternoon
the phone was still in your hand like
this like [ __ ] literally was still to my
face like that [ __ ] and i was like
there's nothing i can say because then i
was skinny then literally nothing you
said there's nothing you say
i was [ __ ] skinny then you weren't
born in america you don't play nfl of
course you gotta be skinny do you know
what i mean do you actually know what i
mean though it's impossible
live in england i started
two years ago
i started pube two years ago you're not
gonna be wedged
the mandem you're looking for are in
jail
you know what i mean
fam
oh i hated that day
oh i can imagine i hate i'm so sorry for
you brother i hated that day so that
that would you ugh what was that would
you say that would be your
worst friend zone yes mine was i
probably said on there before i think i
have
the only one i can remember i was in
year
eight
buried in mine told me about this you
know this one already you said that yes
famous now or something yeah she's a
musician
what it was though
she i asked her out i was feeling her
back then i was feeling her back then
she was a gasolina yeah yeah
yeah so she had a she had a friendship
group right
like four or five
they kind of like ran the show kind of
like a gossip girl type yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah eight so i went up she was the
first one i liked so i went up to i was
like i can't remember what what i said
but long along the lines of i'm feeling
you want to get to know you let's make a
pattern um she was like
yeah i just don't you're nice but i
don't date guys younger than me
big man she's two months older than
months oh than me and i thought
fair enough that's your answer what can
i say i mean you're eight i literally
have no chest
what else can i say bro to be fair i got
friendzoned another time like that
and then um
there was a girl
and uh
[ __ ] this is another brutal one this is
another brutal one
there was a girl that i was friends with
i think i've told you before i fancied
her this was year eight as well
coincidentally yeah this was a year
eight as well yeah i [ __ ] fancied her
bro
like crazy yeah like i would have dreams
about her
wow i fancied her so much it was crazy
yeah yeah and we were also boys
and then we were in math class one day
and she'd got dumped by her boyfriend
the day before okay she came in livid i
think this ring yeah she was like
i can't believe he dumped me and i was
like i can't believe he dumped you
i can't believe he dumped you your ears
were the perfect fam and i was like
that's mad mm-hmm
yeah and the the thing with us is we
have the same birthday okay
so she would always make out she would
every time we had a class together she
would like to teach you like i'll just
like the teacher say we're related okay
let's say we're twins okay so i was like
gang because she was mixed race as well
and i was thinking obviously mixed race
so
and then um
on that math stage she was like i can't
believe he dumped me like it's [ __ ]
annoying and i was like bro i can't
believe it either and then um i was
thinking um this is my chance bro
because me and her start to build a bond
and then she's like oh [ __ ] and she was
like james
if you and my boyfriend would you dump
me and i was like hell
found my at this point my blood ran cold
i was so nervous yeah
my blood ran cold yeah she literally put
a pen i was like james if you're my
boyfriend little smoke would you dump me
and i was like
never and she was like
you're the best she was like you're
actually the best and she was like twins
she wanted this twins and i was like
twins
oh
i'm turned back around i was shaking in
my seat oh you're the best twins fam
you're the best twins
twins g
[ __ ] twins yep yo that's me
that's me
bridesmaid [ __ ] that's me
[Laughter]
i'm a bridesmaid [ __ ] is what you just
said yo
sorry bro
yeah that's tough that's probably the
worst friends i'd have had hundred
percent that's the worst that's worse
than the head the hench guy one
knocked me for six yeah yeah i sat on my
ass but you you you but yeah yeah then i
hit jim and worked up yeah but that fam
can't go back from that
that's terrible twins
twins you're the best
twins
i was shaking i'm shaking right now
because not my boy let's get back to
this let's get back to this [ __ ] you now
um
my mate asked the girl to go to the
smoking area she looked at our other
mate and said only if he's coming too
girls don't give a [ __ ]
listen the thing is i'm not mad at that
because
it's it's a weird complex
like that
sometimes
girls
think that because they've moved to you
this is like a double edged because
girls think they've moved to you they're
entitled to have you
so
if i'm i'm a guy right and i've moved to
a girl if they par you just have to take
that out because that's just the society
we live in yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah but if a girl on a friendly
tips oh you're very attractive you're
handsome come talk to me or a girl says
oh my friend thinks you're attractive
she wants to talk to you if i now say no
i'm okay i'm an [ __ ] oh yeah like why
she's [ __ ] gorgeous like if the
friend got she's [ __ ] gorgeous what
do you mean no i've been there before
bro it's like what are we even
discussing here i've said no politely
what are we discussing yeah
you know so sometimes i get it yeah when
it goes big man i don't want you on your
region yeah sometimes honestly has to be
the thing
yeah it has to be so sorry had to be him
but yeah
told him he's fit and he said this is
why you're my best friend always hyping
me up all the time oh [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off dropped her off at the club
went to pick her up only for her to jump
in the back with another guy like i'm
some uber
can you come pick me up she jumps in
with a breader because he's coming back
to clap cheeks listen to me james
i'm scoop in off the bridge
all three of us are gone
nah
that could never happen
nah
like i'm from uber
take us home take us home
it could never happen
wow got him a cartier ring for his
birthday and he posted it with the
friendship ring as the caption
jesus christ
after i told him i loved him he asked me
to help him choose photos for his hinge
profile
[Laughter]
wow
took a photo with her she said wow we
look like siblings you know uh
i don't know why that resonate i don't
think that's ever happened to me but
like
girls would just say [ __ ] like that
ultimate friendzone
oh my friend
he told me
the holy spirit told him i was a
distraction
[Laughter]
oh serious when they bring god into
these things it sweets me it's too funny
[ __ ] hell
huh
got spoiled and taken out only to make a
move and be told sorry i'm practicing
for the girl i like
i'd be mortified
i'd be mortified if that happened to me
mortified
wow you tickle the you tickle the boxes
i just don't find you attractive can we
play tennis together sometime though oh
[ __ ] you because that's not even friend
zone that's dumping me
and then you want a friend also because
we want yeah you're not even putting me
back in the friend zone you just want
someone somebody just wants someone to
play tennis with yo nuts
nuts oh [ __ ] off
said yes to going on a date then shuts
me down for being too short and didn't
respond afterwards
i told a girl i liked her and instead of
responding
she just asked me for my biology
homework instead
wow
turned up
drunk at his house for some sexy sex
and he asked his mum to take me home
oh wow
oh dear mortified mum can you take her
home please
cause she's just she's just a mess mom
mom can you take her home please
she's out here chatting [ __ ] she's not
my girl mum i promise you she's drunk or
high or sighted she's just trying
non-stop get her out this yard i don't
want that i don't need that
oh [ __ ]
he's torn because he's now
cool
he
he's torn because he's now in a
relationship but i suck his dick just
the way he likes it
from internal
conflict
i've got a girl it's never going to be
you
but same way you just slop it just right
and i'm always on the market for a
throat
but i suck his dick just the way he
likes it black is an mot
like an oil change thing just the way i
like it bread drin
that sent shivers down my spine when i
read that
certain man just don't see women as
human beings
as human beings family
wow funny bro
i like you and you're pretty
but you're big so we'll just be mates
fair though to be i mean
as brutal
understatement but some people need that
i'm 50 50 with that no i'm saying i'm
not saying
that she needs to be told to lose weight
i'm saying that like
some people need i this is this is
twisting it away from the comedy a
little bit but like there's a weird
thing about like
not being able to say your preference
mm-hmm i get what you mean
especially like the heat at the moment
like in that kind of yeah like you are
actually pretty
but you're big and that's a fact
and i'm not attracted to that so we're
boys
that's brutal it's brutal but it's what
how else do you go about it exactly
okay to be fair i should shouldn't have
said she needed that but
um
i'm glad he said it like that like you
are an attractive person in terms of you
don't need to change anything
it's just i don't like big things and
you're you happen to be a big team so no
unfortunately it's a no for me yeah it's
it's just going to have to be a no for
me
and if you lose weight then
ace
but if you want to stay like this also
also ace but for next man yeah next
man's ace yeah
cool
yeah
uh
told me he wanted to be with me and the
next day he said i'm just a really
indecisive person
a man blacked all the way out
family slept on it and said what
i can't leave these streets nah i was
lost yesterday he was lost all up in
that source i'm just a really indecisive
person
wow
i got two more all right go
he wrote a rap saying he liked another
girl and then sent it to me
couldn't even friendzone her in
in person in just regular english just
then he wrote a rap
wow man said read between the lines
literally literally read between these
lines if you don't care you don't get it
mad
first date with her reserved a fancy
restaurant
fancy romantic restaurant she brought
her two best friends with her
i don't i don't think that's acceptable
under any circumstances
yeah yeah it's not and then last but not
least the classic cliche one she told me
i can't wait to meet a guy like you
[ __ ] i am me i literally itch i am
love me i'm here from in your presence
we're stood next to each other love me
need me i want you to want me want me
what want me
please i would scream to the heavens i
will scream to the heavens i'm
everything you want but you literally
don't want me do you know how much of a
pie that is
i'm the guy you want but you can't be
with me
not with me
definitely not me
it's tough man you tickle the boxes but
just not you i see you i think now i
can't ever imagine you [ __ ] me just
um
it's one of them
you're just i don't know what the word
is i don't know what it is you're just
not the the male for me yeah i need a
man you tick these boxes but when i see
you
i dry up yeah my [ __ ] goes
and it's just not what i need for myself
i just spat everywhere i'm sorry it's
what not what i need for myself i want a
gush gosh that's all i need and when i
look at a sponge like you're just nah so
yes you but in a different body does it
take everything that you've got put it
in a man that's what she said
take all these wonderful attributes and
put it in a map being a real man and
that's what i want then come bring him
over then we'll chat oh [ __ ] stress
but yeah anyway that was funny guys
thank you so much as always if you want
to um chill with us on thursday head on
over to patreon.com forwards our shits
and gigs
um
thank you very much love love love
[Music]